you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Leech s
org and I just got paired up playing a
300 game so we will need to go fast no
perfect chess here
let's go it to g3 oh that seems like a
very early rook to b8 let's put a halt
to b5 for at least a moment if b5 is
played now at least to get the a file
and where to go with the night let's go
here and let's see what they do
made f6 and they look to open up this
position I'm seeing a potential tempo
against there Brooke on b8 on Knight f6
I think I could give him a kick with the
e5 um let's go for it there they might
try to hunt down that pond but I'm ok
with gambit in it I'll have a lot of
open blinds so let's move forward a
couple rings with my knight this is
where they could take and they do
fearless Bishop f5 let's make sure I
take first I want to open this guy's
eyes so I'm looking for some knockout
that seems right Knights in a pin could
also think about playing in Knight to c6
if this pawn moves Bishop d6 there's
some discovered attacks like Knight here
hitting at the Bishop and pawn I have a
lot of pieces developed I should have
something Bishop takes Knight Queen h5
seems really good and in the end while I
be hitting these two yeah I think this
is working out the king is gonna have to
step up to e7 so Queen here King King to
e7 and I could even consider playing
here first
although I see nothing wrong with
immediately going in for a queen takes
e5 on King e7 is getting in the bishops
way g6 Queen here hits both rooks
so let me just consider this King King
move here also the knight is within
striking distance I should consider
something like that maybe to give a
check or not just take that pawn yeah
let's go for it so I'm not down any
material and I have a winning attack
it's just a matter of finding it Knight
f5 is an idea this pawn is pinned this
rook is not yet playing so this is
likely a good spot okay the rook is
defended well I think I have a clever
move
let's try rook here Bishop takes pawn
Queen takes here is mate it easily be
overlooked potential pins here knight c6
possibilities this isn't just going for
cheap tricks either because this is just
an active move it's a good move it's not
like some form of hope chess just
threatening the bishop as well and they
resigned
there isn't anything here let me go back
to the analysis board not back let me
just go into it this this rook to b8
move seemed a little bit awkward it
reminded me of uh you know like the
previous flit scheme that I played where
I played rook to b8 trying to get in a
b5 advance and then things opened up and
then it turned out that the rook kind of
looked awkward
and was awkward and I believe that
that's the situation black found
themselves in it's so sure about this
early idea with rook to b8 right here in
fact I'm not so sure about how I played
it with g3 at this moment here I think a
good reply and I've had this played
against me recently in a Syme Oh
is this d5 move just challenging my e4
pawn right away and if I go with
something natural like this I could be
facing this idea or this pawn comes all
the way down and basically cuts my
position in half and it's quite
difficult to work around this idea
so if d5 is played here in reply to g3
let's put on the arrows here well the
suggestion is just to play here but this
is a little bit awkward I must say
because you're playing g3 to play Bishop
g2 so is there something else like is
capturing on right on takes and d5 this
is this is the approach I would take I'm
not playing g3 and then going elsewhere
with my bishop I want to make sure I
keep a watchful eye over these
weaknesses I've created by playing g3 so
short story here is that on g3 if D 5
hits takes takes and then I challenge
these guys right away Knight f6 Bishop
here so just a game yeah just castles
getting your minor pieces out getting
developed both sides will want to make
sure they get their Kings castled since
it's an open e file but yeah of course I
could go into open Sicilian land but ok
g3 rook to b8 I played a 4 yeah
as mentioned
this is uh I could only prevent actually
yeah okay I could only prevent b5 for so
long by playing a for I want to make
sure I get the a file open for my rook
if they are going to be successful with
this b5 advance so I figured why not
insert a 4 B 5 you know it's too it's
too lopsided here you know there's there
is maybe too much attention given by
black to the Queen side rook to b8 a 6 v
v e4 and right around here it's just
it's not something I Cal calculate but
you just sense well you just know like
they're behind in development who cares
if you're gonna drop up on here when you
have so many pieces out and about I
think I played it fine right around here
was calling for d4 you know so they went
upon but I'll have basically every piece
out you know and then this is uh this is
too much
Queen h5 Knight F's Knight f3 I guess
you could pick your favorite way to do
it from here Bishop d7 f4
okay seven and yeah plus five there
isn't really a defense here Bishop here
that would have been a nice mate and
what more if they played Queen here I
could even take here and on pawn takes
Wow
plus nine plus ten takes takes mmm-hmm
yeah well I guess when you're not
playing with the rook and Bishop
sacrifices like this are available Kings
still in the center Queens on the board
Queen White Queen in the center
okay well that one was quick it was a
three minute game but yeah too much too
much attention I guess spent on
queenside development and you know going
pawn hunting probably not a wise choice
with the Kings still being in the center
and these ensuing developing modes you
know like Bishop to f4 Knights hit
Brookes it mmm it's suggesting was like
Queen c7 but that pretty awkward to do
that working yourself into pins rookie
to and the pressure just continues I
guess this is one of the better
continuations and in the end they're not
even going to be up upon I could scoop
him up at some point yeah it's too much
pressure too big of a development lead
okay well as usual feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you